christy is also in olympia washington
and is our first caller of the hour hi
christy how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
okay um i'm a little nervous um so bear
with me
um i've been dying i think i've been
dying to um
have a reason to call you and i finally
do um
we have a house in california that we're
currently
renting out my husband's in the military
we bought the house before he joined
um so we are renting it out currently
we're
not making any money on it um we
consider just raising the rent just to
make ends meet
but my question is um we're due to
we're on track to move again in six
months to new mexico
um ultimately we would love to be back
in california
back into our hometown should we
sell it yes
and i knew that was going to be your
answer but i didn't know what you
thought with the current market
what you thought it would be and um
let's try
let's try reverse engineering it okay
you're in the military and you're moving
from city to city
and you're not going to be in california
for at least five more years
correct and you don't own a house there
let's pretend you don't own a house
there
and you woke up one more and thought you
know what i'm going to go over in this
little town in california and buy a
rental house
that i don't make any money on you would
never do that
right and yet you have yeah
sure so let's undo it sell it
and and okay so now we currently
might be um profiting like a hundred
thousand
would we should we just put that into
something and let it sit there so when
we do
come back to california we got a a big
chunk of change to put down on a house
or should we
buy something in new mexico yeah that
make a great house fund do you have him
diving debt though
no no debt we have um 30 000 in the
savings
wonderful okay yeah i would just take
whatever profits you have of course pay
your taxes on it
and set it aside in a um future real
estate
mutual fund put a mutual fund and just
in your in your mind you could kind of
mark that file
that's my house fund for the future and
you can keep adding to it by the way if
you want to that wouldn't hurt anything
and uh by the way there's not a law that
says that you're necessarily going to
end up back in california when you're
done
five years ago you never dreamed you'd
be where you are right now
that's true we do want to be back in our
hometown with family that would be our
goal and that's
and that's why we have a smaller
mortgage right now with that house
i would just be afraid of coming back to
california and
and then getting into a bigger mortgage
than before just because of the prices
well the problem is you're going to lose
money between now and then and you're
going to wish you had just
not had to fool with this whole thing
you're better off not long-distance
landlording you're better off not
fooling with this it doesn't make sense
and so um and we're not i mean i know
it's your goal to be back there but no
one knows i mean five years is a long
time a lot of stuff happens in five
years yeah things may change
dave you use this example a lot so speak
to the principal
at play there because regardless of the
circumstances christie's question was
about the house but
i hear you say that a lot okay let's
reverse engineer it if this was not true
whatever the circumstances are
would you go do it would you go buy it
would you create it the answer is always
no
right that the question answers it no
not necessarily i mean you know uh
if i didn't own a ski boat
i'd be buying one this week because i'm
going to the lake
this weekend right but i'm saying
something that someone's trying to get
out of i guess
i mean the point is she do i keep it or
do i sell it yes
and you can ask that about anything an
investment you can ask it about
a ski boat you can ask it about um
whatever
but if you look at something and you say
if i didn't already own that i wouldn't
go buy it
for the very reasons that you wouldn't
go buy it you're not using it you don't
like it it's about investment
it's whatever it's the same reasons you
wouldn't keep it
that was what i was going to ask so
whenever you ask the question if this
weren't true would you go do it are
there ever circumstances where
that doesn't apply so you're saying it's
like if the answer is yes i would go do
this today
anyway then then you'd keep then you now
okay you keep it okay
so for instance let's say um the first
place this always comes up is within a
pure investment like let's say
let's say you um bought stock
in i'll just make up a company home
depot
okay about stock at home depot and let's
say you bought it at 75 dollars a share
and it went down to 50 a share
and you said gosh i'm gonna wait on to
come back up i go well
would you buy stock at 50 a share
yeah because i've got real reason to
think it's going to come up right then
you would sit and wait
to come up and you say oh no i wouldn't
buy the 50 a share
i wish i hadn't bought it at 75 a share
because i think it's going to go down
then why then why are you falsely
waiting on it to come back up to be your
measure of when you sell it
you need to say you don't analyze it
based on the past you analyze it based
on the future
yep okay you're forward looking with
your decisions and going
okay if i wouldn't do that again now
then i don't keep doing it just because
of the past yeah
and that's an investment is called a
sunk cost analysis
what you've put into it your cost is
irrelevant as to whether you keep it
virtually irrelevant i mean you may have
some tax implications but it's virtually
irrelevant the the investment analysis
should be and for that matter the
position of a boat should be the future
of that not my family's always had a
boat i've always had a boat this boat's
not been in the water for 10 years it
sits in my garage collecting dust
but but because of the past i'm going to
continue to keep this thing in the
garage
yeah okay well that's dumb yeah but if
you're going to use it this weekend and
you've always used it in the summer
then you would go get a boat or you
would keep your boat in that case
so you're looking forward with all of
your decision-making analysis
uh not the past the weight of the
emotions the
weight of the cost of the item not that
and so you know if you would go and buy
a small house in a small town in
california because you're afraid real
estate prices are going to go up
and if you didn't own it now and you
would go do that now i wouldn't suggest
that but
if you would do it right then maybe you
would keep it different and that's where
we see it the most
every time i host with you it's always
around real estate i had a house
i'm holding the house now i'm renting
out the house and it's another
state and the house is almost always
inherited into that situation meaning
no one set out in those situations to be
a landlord right
right it's a landlord by default is
where most of those questions come from
yes
i became a landlord by default i got
married we moved into
her house but we kept mile house as a
rental that's landlord by default
we're in the military we moved we bought
a house everywhere we've been and every
time we move off we
turn it into a rental property that's
not i decided that's going to be my
rental
investment strategy it's landlord by
default yeah
and it's not wise it almost never leads
you
to a good real estate purchase yeah or
keeping the right piece
of real estate as an investment uh i
i own one piece of property that i
formerly lived in
right now and it's a great rental and i
would buy it again as a rental so i
i passed the acid yeah but but you know
there but but the house i currently live
in
would not be a great rental yeah it's
too stinking ridiculous you know so
not a good idea so it's gonna be sold
yeah no that's the deal